boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are on site in San Mateo California at
the beautiful hero city we are now going
to be talking to Tim Draper hello hello
great thanks for having me on your show
we're super pumped to host you I'm
jazzed
Tim Draper's background for those that
don't know Tim is a world-renowned
venture capital investor founder of
Draper associates Draper Fisher
Jurvetson dfj and Draper University his
venture success has ranged from Skype to
Tesla to Baidu he's credited with
originating viral marketing
he's bullish on Bitcoin taking down fiat
currencies and is passionate about
entrepreneurs driving their visions
through funding education media and
government reform Tim and his family
host meet the Draper's the first reality
show where entrepreneurs pitched their
startups get asked hard questions by
judges and viewers get the opportunity
to you to invest for as little as $10
find all of Tim's links below Timothy
Draper comm Draper VC dfj comm Draper
university comm meet the Draper's comm
as well as his LinkedIn and Twitter
profiles all right Tim let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world you know this is really a great
question because over over the last 50
years if you just watch the news you
think the sky is falling you think the
world is coming to an end but over the
last 50 years
think of how our world has what's
transpired people talk about all the
murders and murder rate is so far down
if people talk about oh we're you know
we're not moving progress along or
whatever the difference between how we
live now and how we live 50 years ago is
extraordinary I mean a lot of people
didn't have still don't but still
running water electricity since then
things like the computer the the
smartphone uber you know some
extraordinary things have happened we've
been able to communicate across around
the world so if you ask me
what I think is gonna be happening
moving forward I think we're gonna we're
gonna have an acceleration of progress
amazing change is gonna happen and I
think we're gonna see the
decentralization of everything of the
world I think the world's going to go
from tribal we were all tribal because
we were sort of protecting our things in
our space and now we're gonna go global
because the the tribes don't matter
anymore the geographic borders matter
much less than they ever did before and
over time I think governments are going
to have to compete a cross border the
way Estonia has already started to do so
this is gonna be a really interesting
time I think we're gonna go through this
amazing there's gonna be an amazing leap
forward for Humanity it's gonna go from
this this world where we really cared
about what the borders were and what our
government said to where we're starting
to start thinking about how are we going
to approach humanity and how how are all
of us going to be doing flying through
the world on this beautiful pearl we
live on ok so throughout the last 50
years yes we've had such an increase in
the quality of life there's been
billions of more people added to the
planet exponential technology is and
geopolitics are a little can you seem a
little hectic at times and some
sometimes things like synthetic biology
can do things like grow meat in bio
reactors and that's fantastic also can
be used as for bio warfare so and with
all the other league you said also
there's these decentralisation that's
occurring from the from the turning the
triangle to a circle the meat of the we
all these types of things how it how are
those the exponential technologies the
geopolitics plus a lot of the issues
with their disconnection from the
planetary spirit how are those coming
together and playing out for you so you
mentioned the population the population
over the last 50 years has gone from
three to eight billion and the next 50
years it's expected to go from 8 to 12
billion most of that growth is going to
be in the African continent that's going
to show we're gonna have a real boom in
Africa because there's gonna be a much
younger population there and that's
gonna be great we're good
one immediate age of about 18 yeah
stands and really booming and Nigeria
will be the biggest of all of those and
so in and I think that that world will
rise and so we're gonna start in some of
the other lesser developed countries are
also going to rise around the globe and
I think we're we're not going to feel so
different going across borders and I so
I think that's going to be really
interesting you mentioned a new
technology that that can do all this
great stuff like you can you can
replicate meat without killing an animal
and you can but you can also use it for
bio air warfare that's always been our
choice whenever there's a new technology
that technology first tends to win all
the wars but it also tends to move
society forward in a magic and
imaginative ways and I think that's
always going to be the case there will
always be the the the group that says
hey how can I use this for power and
then how can I use this to improve
humanity that would be the other group
and the ones I think that are that are
clinging to power right now are I think
are sort of a dying breed
I actually think that humanity is
winning out and it's it has to do with
social media with all the communications
vehicles we have now I I kind of had the
sense that when we had free
communication around the world when we
did hotmail and I came up with a viral
marketing idea well that was going to
really open the world
and it really has so that we're all very
very interconnected and interrelated
through just friendships but also
through businesses and through walks of
life different ways of operating and so
that's when when you see one country
threatening another you think wait a
second that's just that guy that leader
so-called leader being mad at that other
leader because down on the at the at the
human level we already have great
friends in those countries I mean I
think of all this friction between the
US and China
that's friction between the two leaders
of those countries it's not friction
between us we have we have amazing
relationships with all those people in
China I've been working in China for 50
years 30 40 years now
and and had built some amazing
relationships and now I look at any kind
of a war or whatever that kind of the
the danger zone as the equivalent of
just you know shooting off your own leg
in order to you know see if you can
hobble a little faster with your
remaining leg it it really doesn't make
sense except to those leaders who are
trying to cling to power that's that's
going to be the threat that's going to
be we are moving to a new level
Society is moving to a new way of
thinking the leaders have to catch up
and it's interesting the leaders of
these smaller countries are going yeah
how do I do this how do I use Bitcoin
what do I do with you know how do I get
more venture capital here how do I get
more citizens to come to my my country
and there and they're also saying things
like wait how did Estonia do the virtual
citizenship thing how do I do that
how Malaysia already has a virtual
residency program and Kazakhstan is
working on a virtual citizenship program
so there are lots of countries
are all kind of going huh this is
interesting making sure people can't
just disappear off of the face of the
planet for their land or for their money
all different types of things in a
decentralized way you are I'm I really I
love hearing about the you've been here
for doing venture capital here 35 years
the relationship kinda like you said as
well just being able to see the Internet
and the exponential technology age
really flourish thanks to a lot of the
tech and Silicon Valley here and then
seeing the prompts some of the promises
of the Internet when everyone is
connected when there is a true
decentralized way of communication can
then we identify the signal that is
being pushed up and can we then like you
said the power structures that are
trying to hold on to greed or dumb
corruption but rather have those died
out find the signal have those died out
over time that mentality and view seems
to be the one that is we're aiming to
really all transition to and I'm curious
on a on on a spiritual connection to
earth how do you see that maturity for
us are we really connected to the
essence of how we all evolved here
together well it's pretty interesting
because if the the media the press at
least the popular press is is trying to
hold us back going back the other way
I mean they were they're very good at
saying what's happening today but the
idea that we're moving towards something
is not a part of our mainstream media
they're much more concerted on a
military threat somewhere or or friction
between two countries they'd love they
love reporting on that fear they're
actually yeah it's a they self fear is
what really is going on well it turns
out that countries are are not putting
up with that as much anymore so
countries are sort of saying we'll look
we've got a bad dictator we got we got
Facebook we got Twitter
we got a email we can we can spread the
word and have the overthrow of a bad
government and that kind of thing is
going to start happening or I mean
spread the word get out of this country
and leave that guy to fall under his own
weight I think we've got it is going to
be a really interesting time we're going
we're about to go through something that
is more interesting than the internet
more interesting than I think anything
that's happened since we were first
tribal all of a sudden we've got this
new thing humanity is going to go
through this new change and it may not
change again for 20,000 years inclusive
fitness yeah this open open transparent
world that that all kind of figures out
how to operate and I think that that
that figuring out is going to be a
really interesting opportunity and
you're gonna see a number of different
breakthroughs and a lot of it does come
from new technologies new technologies
open the open people's eyes to new ways
of thinking the who ever imagined that
people in the city would would try to
operate without automobile now it's like
simultaneously yes yes it's
simultaneously it's also doing the
addiction process to the variable reward
system that are the news feeds rather
than the connection to the trees the
plants the animals the Sun the the thing
that gives us life here so there's
simultaneously technology causing a
disconnection from source from spirit
while it also causes us to be able to
talk to each other across the world yeah
I don't know what it is in humans that
want that fear in their head we're less
fearful now basically there's less to
worry about
really I mean less life threatening
things to worry about and so they're
looking
those because that's the way we were
made it was like fight or flight and
running or whatever and that fear thing
is a little bit of like a it it lights
up the brain it's like whoa way I'm
afraid let me go figure something out
well now that figure something out is
just you know you know you can figure
stuff out in your business or your life
or whatever your love life a lot of ways
to figure things out but if if you've
already kind of got all those things
kind of figured out you you rely on the
news to give you that fear thing that
sends off the endorphin that that drives
it and it yes it does take a lot of the
soul out of society and and people
really do need to detox away from the
news and parse for signal with greater
vigilance yeah thinking get connected
with the world around them the people
around them connecting with people I've
seen a lot less connections with people
I don't Lee because of that and I've
seen a lot less connection with nature
and the animals and the plants of the
world I you see a lot less of that and
that's why we all of a sudden there's
all this this attachment to dogs or to
their cats yeah there's people who feel
family rather than that Global Village
vibe which we're in many ways we're
heading to Tim a couple couple more
let's do some rapid fire stuff and then
if we can we may come back and do
another round with you on rapid fire
stuff 35 years venture capital Silicon
Valley give us a profound take away from
what this experience has been like
well technically 33 years 33 bias that's
34 well maybe it's 30 poin our get in
there so it'll ask me again and I'll say
wait was that 33 as you get older you
missed those years so here's here's the
way it looked way back when it was very
much a gentlemen's club
and they all kind of got together and
they saw an entrepreneur and they said
I'll throw a little money and I'll throw
a little money in and and why don't we
just say we'll split it with the
entrepreneur 5050
well that that did very well and and so
more money went in more people watched
more people realize that hey I can do
that too and so it has spread and
venture capital and entrepreneurship has
spread to where now rather than me going
door to door and knocking or knocking on
any door that said something software
now I am bashed we have something like
20,000 business plans that come to my
email address every year a year yeah and
Wow so we're and I'd get to fund about
20 or 30 of them but you can also
distribute the ones that you think today
start work so but there are lots of
other venture capitalists there are lots
of ways to do venture capital there was
the possibility that I CEOs would
replace venture capital crypto Bitcoin
have really kind of changed things
eventually I believe that that I'll be
able to raise a fund in Bitcoin put it
out in Bitcoin have the entrepreneurs
pay their employees and suppliers in
Bitcoin and then have the whole thing
built into a smart contract so that my
investors get exactly what they're due
at the exact time they're due yes and
and it could end up being a really great
experience and an inclusive stake
holding today's consumers all this thing
that gives lawyers and accountants more
they can give you more abstract advice
rather than the boring stuff that they
that they have to spend 90% of their
time doing kind of brings brings up AI I
one way to look at the world is
everything is going to be replaced by AI
so just think about what you're what
part of your job is mundane yes that
will be replaced by AI and then think
how will you respond how do you do
better with this new world
and it's kind of fun to think about I I
could there are a lot of things that I
do repetitively and I would be happy to
do those by AI so that I was freed up to
do other thing to your creative flow
States okay Tim let's talk about what
the transition has been with
civilization over the last thousands of
years we had money come into play and
now with the internet and the
decentralization of of things and the
speed at which we can just do something
like communicate in the exchange of
value with digital currency that's on
there decentralized ledger rather than a
centralized currency this is a massive
moment with being able to exchange value
this is why you are I think so bullish
on cryptocurrencies and so I want you to
to just give us that that that core
essence of like internet exponential
technology digitization of currency why
is it so profound so most currencies
were started just because people trusted
them it was like the promise of gold or
started out being shells and you know
then it was gold and then it was the
promise of gold now it was a promise
that the government would back you up
which is a little less of a promise well
and that was a given government and that
government was tied to a geographic
territory all of a sudden we have a
currency that is not tied to a
government and not tied to a geographic
territory
well that frees us because governments
have always used that currency to
control us to in some ways keep keep
controls over that currency well this
frees us we can we can operate across
border much easily we can move money
across border much easily much more
easily and and we reduce the friction
significantly you know you know you
wonder why are those banks so big and
those bankers also rich why are they all
dressed so well
it's because two and a half to four
percent of every transaction you ever do
is picked up by the credit-card company
and the bank gets the bulk of that that
would go away and so you do see the the
banks feeling threatened here and for
good reason because if you use Bitcoin
instead of dollars you the banker
doesn't control your Bitcoin he controls
your dollars so I think you have this
new opportunity for a currency that is
is frictionless not no two and a half to
four percent transparent everybody can
see exactly where it goes so you keep
perfect records it is open its
cross-border so you can use it anywhere
you can go from one country to another
pull down your Bitcoin and everything's
fine and and it's a great store of value
but it's also going to be faster than
the visa network so this is going to be
one of those things where it's like it's
a sea change that there is new
technology and it is better faster
cheaper than anything else out there
we're gonna move that way and
governments have to figure out how
they're going to adapt to not
controlling everybody through the
currency beautifully synthesized and
also the underlying technology of
blockchain you were giving some examples
earlier about being able to have people
be identified also to have smart
contracts you you gave a couple examples
of that as well a some other rapid-fire
things on the way out what are your
thoughts about what happens pre birth
and post death oh that's fun pre birth I
haven't spent a lot of time on pre birth
but I know post death we're still
connected so that is a really I just
know we are because I and I didn't I
wasn't a hundred percent sure until my
mom died and she she left us with this
rainbow spectacular rainbow that came
from nowhere and and all of a sudden
there was this spectacular rainbow and I
thought because we were all sort of
flipping out we had just lost our mother
and just by going outside all of a
sudden we saw this spectacular rainbow
and we've seen there have been other
sort of interesting signs I won't go
into all of them there is more and I
think that after that at first they they
want to make sure like when people die
they want to make sure that everything
goes according to their plan and after
that I think they have another adventure
and so that over time they they move on
to their other adventures so I think
there is more and I don't know whether
the two things are linked whether you
you know if you do well here you do well
there but I do know that we're connected
I also believe that we're interconnected
with each other throughout the world how
many times have you thought of somebody
and then seen them at the grocery store
about an hour later that kind of thing
we are all interconnected so there are
all of these or maybe neurons firing in
here and there may be by the way your
gut actually actually does have a brain
to it and so your brain and your gut not
only are in this body but they are also
connected with all these other bodies we
are interconnected where we're actually
connected with the plants and animals
too and I think those connections are
not as easy not as strong but they are
there and and then the before birth it
could be that adventure you were talking
about the next they could be in a
previous adventure no previous adventure
to this next I mean what's interesting
is I don't know if other people have
felt this but I have felt that I would
get some new piece of educational
material and I'll look at it and I'll go
I already know this and I know it's new
to my life but I already know it I'm not
sure why that is or how that happened
but I already know it so I think that
there are things that that connect from
previous life to now and from now to
future life and so I'm you know after my
mom died all of a sudden I realized hey
it's okay it it's okay we're this is
just a part of a longer much more
extraordinary adventure and story okay
Lizzie and then there's something I
always like to serve throw out to my
students and to other people look up at
the stars and realize that you're just
on this little marble flying through
space pearl like that look up at the
stars and then and then think how
amazing how many stars there are and all
that think of is there an end to that
and then you think wait if there's an
end what are you boxed in how does that
work or is there no end to that and both
are equally freaky to think of that I
love drapery University I love what you
do with like the youth they're there so
from around the world they're coming
together and you're helping them with
entrepreneurship telling them these
stories Tim how about arena simulation I
[Laughter]
don't think so
I think there are too many fun
interesting things where you can you can
control them and make interesting new
things happen you can go mold your
future you can mold your the service
you're gonna provide to people you can
you can do so many things with your life
you know I'm maybe there is some watcher
or I'm not sure and the last one is
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world love love love is all you need
thank you so much for coming on really
very casual we would love for everyone
to check out Tim's links in the bio
below give us your thoughts in the
comments we would love to hear from you
also go and talk to more people around
the world your friends your family
co-workers people online on social media
about the topics that we discussed in
this episode and the power that they
actually have for our future and support
our CH artists entrepreneurs people in
your communities that you believe in
support simulation our links are below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace